معنى من عمان لواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي لوق فايز دخول
مقاتلات الاف 16 هل من شانه ان يغير فعلا
معطيات المعركه في اوكرانيا
يعني لا يمكن الاجابه بنعم او لا لانه
الاجابه تقع في المنطقه الرماديه لماذا
يجب ان لا نتحدث عن الطائره كرقم مجرد
علينا ان نتحدث عن منظومه
متكامله اولا ما هي اعداد للطائرات التي
يتم ارسالها البيان الاول يتحدث عن دفعه
اولى من الطيارين ست طيارين اذا اعداد
متواضعه الامر الاخر ما هي البنيه التحتيه
اللازمه لاستخدام الطائره بكفاءه عاليه
جدا من حيث المطار منظومه الصيانه ما هي
انواع الصواريخ لانه عندما نتحدث
وكانت جو جو او جو ارض ما نوع الصاروخ
هناك
طروز متخلفه مختلفه ترازات متعدده اذا
هناك مجموعه من العوامل اذا قدمت الطائرات
الحديثه والمتطوره اف دي فستحدث فارقا
جوهريا لانها طائره مكافئه لطائره سو 35
من الجيل الرابع
اذا ادخلنا طائره
خوذه الطيار والمنظومه الراداريه لكن اذا
قدمت النماذج اللي هي
فهذا لن يكون بمستوى
اذا هناك مجموعه من العوامل لكن هذه
الطائره هي طائره تفوق جوي طائره مكافئه
لاحدث الطائرات الروسيه ستحدث فرقا اذا
توافرت الشروط والعوامل التي تحدثت عنها
يعني بالمعدل كم يحتاج التيار من التدريب
من الوقت للتدريب على هكذا طائرات متى من
المتوقع ان تدخل هذه الطائرات المعارك
بالفعل
الجانب الاوكراني يتحدث عن بدايه الصيف
القادم لانه الان عندما نتحدث هذه الطائره
تعتبر من الطائرات المعقده من حيث
الاستخدام واسلوب المناوره وبالتالي تحتاج
الى تدريب طويل زمنيا وتدريب مكثف لكن
السؤال هل سيتم ارسال اشخاص
مدنيين يبدا بالتدرب ام سيتم ارسال طيارين
سبق لهم مع مئات
وربما
عشرات المئات من الطلعات على الطائرات
الاخرى وبالتالي لديهم خلفيه كافيه ويكون
هنا تدريب عمليه التحديث وتطوير لقدراته
القتاليه على الطائرات الاخرى هنا يحتاج
الى عده اشهر بينما في في الوضع الاخر
يحتاج الى سنوات بما ترجح موافقه واشنطن
الان على تسليم هذه الطائرات لاوكرانيا
يعني تعثر الهجوم المضاد
احرج واثقل كاهل الغرب كانت كان الرهان
على هذا الهجوم انه سيحقق الكثير لكن تم
التغطيه بان الحديث الان عن المراه الحاله
التمهيديه والهجوم الرئيسي او الجراند
ارمي لم يتم توظيفه هذا الامر خلق مشكله
للغرب من حيث التزويد بالذخيره المطلوبه
من حيث اضعاف قدرات الجيش الروسي على
الاستمرار وبالتالي كان لابد من التصعيد
في التسليح من اجل احداث تغيير جوهري على
الارض
طيب لواء فايز هذا التغيير الجوهري كم
تذاكرت في بدايه الحديث عن عدد الطائرات
بان اي فرق على الارض يحتاج الى عدد
طائرات معين سرب معين وهنا نتحدث عن كم
طائره بتقديرك يمكن ان تحدث فرقا لانه
تبدو كل التصريحات من الجانب الاوكراني
متفائله
يعني الان الجانب يعني هناك نسبه من حيث
المخزونات الموجوده حاليا هي واحد الى
عشره تقريبا ما بين القدرات الاوكرانيه
مقابل القدرات الروسيه 176 طائره مقابل
1511 طائره ما بين مقاتله ومعترضه اذا
الميزان مختل جدا وبالتالي لتسكير هذه
الفجوه مع اعتبار انتقل المتطوره والحديثه
يجب على الغرب ان لا يقدم اقل من 100
طائره شكرا لك فايزه دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه كنت معنا من عمان